our heavenly father once again we want
to ask for your blessing as we continue
with his class I ask for heightened
awareness and alertness for the students
lord it's been a long week and I just
pray Lord that you will bless us all now
as you uh Enlighten our minds once again
in regard to the gift of Prophecy we ask
it in Jesus name amen
first of all I didn't say this yet I
need to say I appreciate you all uh
doing the class today
coming today I know it's been a long
week and I just wanted to tell you I
appreciate it
um
and uh
it's been a really long week
I had something else but it's fleeted
against that's what happens this one's
gonna happen when you guys get old
this must have been a long week that's
right
um has it has it been a blessing have
you do you feel like you've gained out
of the class
um do you feel like you grasp a a little
clearer understanding of our Bible
foundation for the gift of Prophecy
um it's not like we just ice Revelation
12 17.
you know there's a lot of solid
scripture evidence
back into the discussion on dress a
little bit uh before I do that somebody
had asked me about the quote here's one
place councils and diets and Foods page
211.
paragraph three
if you air
let it not be in getting as far from the
people as possible
for then you cut the threat of your
influence and can do them no good
better air on the side of the people
than all together away from them for
there is hope in that case that you can
carry the people with you
but there is no need of error on either
side
it's good
true
middle of the road statement there
middle the right Road I should say
okay now back on the subject of address
again
um
a couple things obviously the issue of
modesty
um and I just I heard a powerful sermon
anybody here know who uh
Joshua Harris is
yeah I Kissed Dating Goodbye guy heard a
powerful sermon by him on his uh website
entitled are you committing pornography
I thought that's interesting what's it
about
and in his sermon he addressed the fact
that just as somebody may open a
pornographic picture and look at that
the person who advertises themselves to
be photographed is committing
pornography and then he said to the
ladies ladies are you committing
pornography and I think that's a good
question to ask when we're looking in
reasoning from principle
when you're when you know
I I feel for the ladies today because
men are perverts they are and even
Christian men because of our carnal
Natures now I'm not excusing it I'm
going to tell you something guys I
worked in a when I where I used to work
I worked with Christian guys in the
office like before I was a pastor I
worked for an electrical contractor
had guys and they'd come in and they
talk about the new Britney Spears
commercial and how hot she was and other
things like that married men
I want to tell you I don't do and
haven't done anything like that since I
got converted I wish I could say since
I've been married
but it wasn't since I've been married
now you hear what I'm saying but when I
got converted I changed
and conversion ought to change that that
doesn't mean we're not still tempted
but the point is you don't give in to
that anymore you don't even go down that
road you know I've got Christian men
they'd leave them through the Victoria's
Secret catalog brother put that thing
down
you know okay get the victory no wonder
no wonder
okay ladies please help us out
please help us out by following
principles of modesty and dress now
Ellen White's Council on dress dealt
with modesty it also dealt with health
there are unhealthy ways to dress
um
now these days our clothing is quite a
bit different in a sense some of it's
probably not nearly as heavy in fact
I don't think I need to say any more
right there
but very lightweight
um
I think uh that the clothing that we
wear for ladies and gentlemen should
look nice should look neat
um this idea uh some of the guys today
the young guys going around wearing
these pants looks like they're carrying
a load in their pants
I can't think of a better way to put it
I don't think that's I don't think
that's appropriate dress
I'm sorry for the I just that's the only
way that's not appropriate dress a
Christian ought to dress neatly and
modestly okay now I read this statement
recently I'm going to share with you
when we went out door to door in in
Mission College the big thing was
the bit
I apologize but I hope I didn't offend
anybody over that but I'm just telling
you this is the reality okay
in Desire of Ages page 351 when I was in
Mission College we you know when you go
out to the doors how do you dress you
know there's always some people had we
always wear shirt tie suit pants you
know at least it's like you know I
struggle with that I read this statement
in Desire of Ages I'm going to share it
with you Ellen White says page 351 on
this first tour when Jesus sent out the
seventy
the disciples were to go only where
Jesus had been before them and had made
friends
nothing must be allowed to divert their
minds from the great from their great
work or in any way excite opposition and
close the door for further labor they
were not to adopt the dress of the
religious teachers nor use any guise in
their apparel to distinguish them from
the humble peasants
their efforts were to be put forth in
house to house labor now how do I
interpret that I interpret that to say I
don't wear suit and tie when I go out
I I wear something that looks
I wear something that looks nice and
something that looks neat and clean you
know I'm not wearing baggy pants and all
this I'll wear something like I'm
wearing now in the summertime obviously
short sleeve shirts Etc but
you know
um
I think that uh that that needs to be
understood in regard to dress
your dress should be neat your dress
should recommend your Christianity
um Ellen White talks about wearing uh
having special clothes for Sabbath I
don't mandate a person who wears a suit
on the Sabbath I think if you dress in a
suit I think it looks very nice and I've
told people I like my church officers to
have suits Ben and I have been with that
Ben was my head Deacon in Hastings and
uh we went around with this some of the
deacons didn't like uh didn't he like to
iron their clothes I said brother you
know the one guy I don't like wearing
ties I said I'm not going to tell you
wear a tie but iron your clothes before
you come to church okay but
but sister white did counsel that we
should have
a special outfit for the Sabbath
not just picking in the closet and
anything else Sabbath is special it just
keeps in our mind I think that Sabbath
is special our dress should be modest
our dress should be comfortable it
should not be restrictive
um it should not be exceptionally tight
um
you know ladies I'm gonna tell you what
you buy off the racks these days a lot
of times and if if you've been a
cognizant of this you've had a hard time
shopping I'll tell you right now you
know you know honey is this uh you know
you go to Honey is this this is our
little two-year-old sure no that's my
shirt honey you know no I mean you get
he looks like these days
and and I'll tell you what it just you
need to keep these principles in mind
you don't want to be a stumbling block
for somebody
dress neatly dress modestly try to keep
it covered up
amen
now the issue of pants this is something
where I've had people confront me on
this and there are some people take
strong positions women should wear
dresses women should not wear pants
pants is abominable and so part of the
part of this comes in with I think the
American costume see the American
costume was a dress that was like a suit
type jacket and a an address that came
down to about here and had pants
underneath it okay
one thing that Ellen White recommended
to ladies generally at least in cooler
weather was to wear something under
their dresses to keep their legs warm
okay now I'm not and I'll tell you what
also ladies I think dresses look much
nicer when you go into the house of the
Lord I really think
pants and even pant suits I got people
wear pants I I just I I think that a
dress has a very important purpose and I
think they look very nice they look very
ladylike
um to say you would have a dress all the
time see this is where it comes well
what happens you're working in the
garden you're riding a horse I'll be
honest with you I think we're in a dress
in some of those situations could be
very modest
or lend to it you following what I'm
saying okay and so the question is you
know some people say well but some
people will affirm that Ellen White
counsels she doesn't really say anything
about pants okay well they'll affirm
that Ellen White says you shouldn't you
know this that and the other
in regard to pants one thing that I've
found and I've not thoroughly studied
this out so I don't want you to say well
Pastor Howard said any more than sister
white said but um
my wife one thing that seems to be
significant in the issue of the pants
was that in Ellen White's day
as you had things coming out like
Bloomers which were early pants and the
American costume those outfits were
strongly associated with the women's
Liberation movement
and when our people would adopt that
clothing and you'll see references to
this in her writings in the context
people would view Adventists as being
part of these part of the women's
Liberation movement she didn't want the
reproach on our cause
you follow that
and so I'm I'm leaning that way from
what I've read and I've read a good bit
on it but I've got to look at my wife
has looked at it extensively my wife
usually wears dresses
you know but even in light of it we've
discussed it and um
you know is there some is there some
total ban on wearing pants uh there are
a lot of you know a lot of the pants
today uh accentuate things that they
probably it would be better to wear
something either different or not quite
so accentuating
you follow what I'm saying
um
but when you're applying the principles
of dress dress is one of these things
you can take an extreme on and I think
to make this statement that all you can
wear I don't condemn anybody for wearing
dresses either all the time I mean like
I said my wife wears them most the time
she doesn't wear when she's gardening
and riding a horse and riding the bike
Etc but there are some people who feel
that it's a violation I mean I had one
uh person who said Who would wear a
dress all the time and they'll say no do
you wear it in garlic absolutely riding
the horse I wear dress all the time
and so I think I don't think that
position is is uh the middle of the
straight road
okay do you follow what I'm saying you
kind of pick up the principles that I'm
hitting on I'm not going to tell you how
to dress
understand the principles
don't lean towards your inclination
either and not just in dress in anything
try to stand with what God teaches with
the principles God's given you follow
that
you mad at me
ladies are like
do you agree with me yeah you ladies
have you had to process this stuff
you know you guys I'm pretty I'm
preaching to the choir here
you know
I'm not preaching to the angry Saints
all right one other thing I want to
touch on there's other things on the
list one thing I want to touch on is the
wedding band
there's a lot of controversy in the
Adventist Church about the wedding band
I'm just going to tell you very simply
first let me ask you how many of you
have read what Ellen White says about
the wedding band yourself
a lot of people when they come to the
wedding band and they say oh well
um you know Sister white says have you
read it no since Wright says the church
says we can wear it
what is it what did she say about it if
you read what Ellen White says and
testimonies to ministers page 181
the situation arose where Ellen White's
um
daughter-in-law was getting married in
Tasmania
the culture in Tasmania and the custom
in Tasmania was such that it would have
been a reproach on the truth
for her not to have the band on her and
her husband Willie her daughter her son
Willie and and and his wife I think it's
Emma am I right on that does that mean
where they would they were traveling
around doing Ministry and to travel
around on these trains Etc here he is a
minister his wife doesn't have a wedding
band on her hand in Tasmania that would
tell everybody this man's not even
married to this woman okay and so she
said and her parents Emma still wasn't
going to wear it and her parents were
were livid about it now I might says go
ahead and wear it well we're get around
sister white says we can wear the
wedding band sister white says we can
wear the wedding band so in testimonies
to ministers 181 she responds
she says my I am I am
how does she how does it start out
basically says I am
troubled
over this leavening process that's
coming in amongst our church
our people are adopting the customs of
the world we don't need the customs of
the world we don't need a wedding band
to show that we're married not one spent
Penny should be spent on a circle of
gold to testify to the fact that we're
married our vows should be evident in
how we act and then she says in those
countries where the customer is
imperative we don't feel we don't
condemn those who adopt the practice but
and she clarifies again you read the
statement
her position is not one of endorsement
it's not it counsels against it but
we've got people they want to be like
the world we've got Adventists who've
been in the church 20 years and then
this this big thing comes about and they
say hey we're allowed to wear the
wedding band they go out and buy them
what in the world is that all about
you know and waste the Lord's money on
something I I don't wear a wedding band
and let me tell you something when I did
before I became an Adventist it doesn't
stop people from hitting on you that's
right
some girls think it's great to uh it's a
challenge
and it's true
wedding band doesn't doesn't make the
difference and how many people do you
know who get married with wedding bands
who aren't married anymore
I I haven't worn a wedding band in 12
years 10 11 years and my wife and I have
been married for nearly 20.
amen and so it's not the wedding band
that makes it okay and and so understand
don't take these extreme positions
just to suit your own fancy whether it's
on one side or the other
always ask yourself what's truth and try
to take your stand on that amen you with
me on all that any questions
before we move into the next
uh the cult Scare Tactics Etc
let's let's pull out the other handout
and we're going to go into this
last part here
oh one thing I did want to mention as
well
because I just brought him in here
I always thought it was interesting to
me
that
Ellen White talks about card playing
and that is a No-No
this is an Uno
this is okay and this one's not what's
up with that anybody ever figure that
out
anybody ever read the council at all it
has on card playing checkers
Etc you ever wondered about that
does anybody have an answer
competition could be one
remember there are principles in it now
understand in Ellen White's day if you
had a deck of cards out what were you
typically doing yeah gambling what else
probably drinking and smoking right
just like the pool halls just like the
bill she talks about bowling you know I
went I was bowling when I was a kid
families go bowling it wasn't like that
in her day you go to the bowling Hall
the guys are out there getting drunk
smoking cussing right
so understand you've got to understand
kind of the setting around some of these
things I just I saw these cars sitting
up here you know it's just funny
sometimes Adventists will follow through
these things their whole lives I play
you know I don't play that could you
have a similar problem with these
I mean one other thing on games is the
the time it wastes
anybody ever play Monopoly till the wee
hours of the morning
so
for crying out loud and sometimes you've
got you know that's a colossal waste of
time so that there's that aspect too is
the is this an evil thing no not even
this one in and of itself
you know but evidence I guess appearing
avoiding the appearances of evil we'd
use this one but you know what I'm
saying
but you need to understand the principle
behind what you're doing there's nothing
worse than somebody who's doing it and
they have no clue why
that's how I grew up I asked my teacher
once I I can't believe I actually found
this too I asked my teacher once teacher
in seventh grade my Adventist teacher
why did Ellen might say we shouldn't
drink milk
first of all she didn't say we shouldn't
drink milk she said the time would come
would it be best not to use milk okay
but that's what I understood it and I
asked my teacher and his response to me
was well
in Ellen White's day they used chalk to
color the milk they would water it down
and then they would use chalk to keep
the white color and that's why she said
that
and I actually read that in something
just recently as I was reviewing for
this class that I thought oh have mercy
that's not why we have counsel against
military against disease in the animal
kingdom don't give some stupid ideas
that that's the same thing with the
chickens period with the egg that we
were talking about the other day that's
ridiculous don't give some crazy answer
like that know why you believe what you
believe
why don't you play cards well I don't
know
you know we just don't do it why because
my church says we're not supposed to
that's not a good reason okay are you
with me on that okay let's get to this
next part let's open our Bibles to
revelation 12.
verse 17.
I want somebody to read this text who
wants to read it for me Revelation 12 17
Ezekiel the prophet false prophet Zeke
Kansas got my eye on you
I've got my eye on you he may just come
through I'm stumbling I'm still still
waiting I told him after the break he
said he's our he's our Prophet to La
Sierra well he's back out there he's
gonna
I have confidence in you brother you're
going to straighten it out
uh Revelation 12 17 why don't you read
that for me you listen carefully and I
want you to tell me from that verse our
identifying characteristics of God's
Remnant Church
go ahead and read it and the dragon was
enraged with the woman and he went
war with
okay what are our identifying
characteristics there
okay it's the remnant what is it what
are the characteristics that the Bible
breaks down to identify
what's that
keep the Commandments of God
you keep quiet man
you got that one too quick what's the
other one
okay
gift of Prophecy
what else
is that an identifying characteristic
you bet it is you bet it is the dragon
is what does he say
Roth anybody else have another
dragon is enraged
it's an Old English word Roth
where wrath comes from angry and raged
now I just want to say right off the bat
when people come to me and say pastor
you say you're part of the true church
but I went on the website and I've got
all this garbage I've heard all this
what do you got to say about that I say
praise the Lord that's the third
characteristic
right
if we did not have I said this the other
if we did not have the opposition that
we have on the spirit of Prophecy we
would not be in the right Church
The Remnant church has these two
characteristics and the devil is enraged
with her specifically because of these
two characteristics he can't stand God's
law and he can't stand the church that
keeps God's law or as a gift of Prophecy
that guides them towards the keeping of
God's law
you follow that
and so the dragon is enraged with a
woman and because of that we have uh
oops that uh number two shouldn't have
been there I was going to delete that
out
I put this together this morning so
we'll skip over that the introduction is
basically what I just said we're gonna
move in we've got we've got attacks in
this church and they come from outside
and from inside we're going to look at
the outside attacks first
cult Scare Tactics you know nobody likes
to be called a cult
any more than anybody likes to be called
a legalist right
there are some times that you're going
to act as a faithful Seventh-day
Adventist and somebody's going to say
you're being a legalist and our initial
reaction is
I've been called a legalist and we want
to change what we're doing
okay the dev this is a the devil likes
this cult word he'll throw that out
there so he can scare us
you know oh we're being called a cult
well we don't like the being called part
of a cult but I want you to look with me
to acts 24 and verse 5.
acts 24
and verse 5 who wants to read that one
for me
you guys in the back never read anything
can you read something Caleb can you
read acts 24 verse 5.
amen
acts 24 verse 5.
don't you go ahead
oh okay
and this
and we have found this man on play one
who stirs up rise among all the Jews
throughout the world and is the ring
leader of the sex of the Nazareth okay
they're speaking of the Apostle Paul's
got these men coming in and they're
saying we found this man Paul uh creator
of dissension among all the Jews
throughout the land he's a ringleader of
the what
yes
Kevin where were you brother
all right uh now that word sect is the
same word as cult it's the same word
they said this man and Paul he's part of
that cult that believes in Jesus
this is not a new thing
this is not a new tactic that the
devil's using Paul was called the leader
of a cult look at verses 12 to 14 with
me
it says and neither they neither Paul
defending himself says they neither
found me in the temple disputing with
anyone nor inciting the crowd either in
the synagogues or in the city nor can
they what
prove the things of which they now
accuse me
keep this in mind okay
you find this throughout the New
Testament
nobody could gain say what Paul said
nobody could overthrow his arguments
they were solid Paul was solid in what
he taught and when a person can't
overthrow your argument
the next best thing is to defame you and
your character
because like I said before you see that
note underneath straw man arguments
what's a straw man for what's a
scarecrow for scarecrows away a strong
man argument is to scare people away why
because if they investigate they're
going to find there's nothing to it okay
Paul's truth was solid and these men
knew that if people got in and heard
what Paul said they're going to believe
it
what are we going to do about that we
can't undo his arguments he preaches
from the same Bible we do and he just
puts us to shame every time
I know we'll tell everybody he's member
of a cult
he's seditious he's causing trouble and
people say oh I don't want to go there
yeah you don't want to go there he'll
brainwash you man
and that's exactly what happened
and Paul makes the point here hey look
they can't prove anything they're
selling against me and they couldn't
prove it that's why they attacked the
messenger because they couldn't get
anything in on the message you follow
that that's exactly what we're seeing
today isn't it that's why we're seeing
the attacks today brothers and sisters
our message is so solid
and uh
for that reason the devil knows if
people get in and hear it
and have time to process it
they're going to believe it
so he scares him off
look at John 7 48 Matthew Mark Luke John
7.
48.
no would you like to go ahead
just for the sake of time go ahead read
it I had it in the notes and I just I'm
looking at my time but go ahead
excellent excellent and thank you for
bringing that back up the way that they
call a cult he says uh pardon me
incidentally by the way that what
they're calling a cult
it's the same thing that their
forefathers wrote I follow all of it
you know I'm not out of line with what
God teaches in his word
this thing that they're calling a cult
so Paul gives a Vindication of his of
his uh
stand there but once again he uses that
same that same phrase same thing we're
dealing with today
um
John 7 48 says this
have any let's look at verse
45. pick up in verse 45.
then the officers came to the chief
priests and Pharisees who said to them
why have you not brought him you see
they they sent these Roman soldiers over
to arrest Jesus
so they go over there to arrest him and
as they went to arrest him and they were
just waiting for the opportune time they
listened to him speak and as they listen
to him speak well we'll go get this
Jesus he's stirring up trouble we
believe you guys we're going to go over
and listen to him speaking that's not
quite exactly what we thought now and I
say listen more they come back
empty-handed
so the rulers asked him why haven't you
brought not brought this man verse 46
the officer said no man ever spake like
this man
and the Pharisees answered them and said
are you also deceived have any of the
rulers of Pharisees believed in him
did they refute Jesus message no could
they no so what'd they do
well if this is true why doesn't
everybody believe it
now if you haven't heard that yet you're
going to
you have a study interest and you tell
them about the Sabbath it's plain as day
they look at it and they go but if this
is true
then why doesn't everybody believe it
well that's an old argument
they used it on Jesus
if this is true why hasn't everybody
believed it so
these are called Scare Tactics they want
us to think that oh this is a minority
group they're not following the Bible
they got these crazy beliefs why because
if people investigate them the devil
knows what's going to happen and this is
why we have these things in our church
defaming the character I'm not going to
go into that that's just more texts that
talk about how continually you had
groups following the Apostle Paul around
trying to discredit the person
and make them question the person in his
authority
because they couldn't discredit his
message
you follow that
okay so let's go into the plagiarism
charges these are the one this is one of
the big things that we deal with today
first thing I want you to do is go with
me to the Book of Ecclesiastes not
before I even do that before I even do
that
I'm going to have you jump ahead
I'm going to have you jump ahead to
letter c letter B rather
where I pick it up again
I want you to notice some definitions
here
number one the word plagiarism comes
from a Latin word plagiarium which means
kidnapper okay it is defined in the
American Heritage dictionary as to use
and pass off as one's own plagiarism is
a literary masquerade as somebody said I
believe Roger Kuhn said that in other
words plagiarism is where I write
something that is all from somebody else
and I tell you in the plagiar plagiarism
is when I have a report due at school
and I go on to Incarnate encyclopedia
and I copy the whole article and I take
it in and I delete everything and put my
name to it and I say here and the
teacher says this is astounding did you
write this and I said every word of it
that's plagiarism okay
plagiarism
as let's look at this the number two
there literary borrowing on the other
hand occurs when a writer utilizes and
employs the words of another for the
purpose of making a particular Point
example sermon illustrations those who
have preached who writes your sermon
typically you do although you're allowed
to use other sermons but if you write
your own sermon and you get the points
together how many of you have done that
and then pulled a sermon illustration
from somewhere I need a good story where
do I get a story hey I heard a good
story somewhere you've just borrowed
okay
you've borrowed from something else does
that mean you didn't write what you
wrote does that mean the guy you
borrowed from gave your sermon wrote
your sermon put it together no you just
borrowed an idea that got across the
thought you and your own mind had
conceived to get across you follow that
that's different from plagiarism you're
not masquerading as somebody trying to
trying to put up put off that you have
written what somebody else has written
you follow the illustration there
literary law number three recognizes
what is defined as fair use of the ideas
and even the words of another it's not
illegal to use other words people do it
all the time
it is illegal to take a whole person's
thought an article and put it in and say
it's mine okay
it's not illegal to take a thought out
of something you read here and say I'm
going to incorporate this thought and
give it and never give credit for it
that's not illegal people do that all
the time
not everything we say and do is
copyrighted I have no issue if somebody
in this class says you know I I that was
a good thought and you jot it down word
for word what I said in something and
you reuse it somewhere
you know that's not that's literary
borrowing okay legally that's understood
to be that's a common practice it was a
common practice in Ellen White's day
people didn't accuse you know the
authors of some of these books they know
nobody accused her in her day about
taking their stuff
it was common literary practice but
we're going to talk about a little bit
more detail there I want you to see the
difference there in the Bible there are
examples of literary borrowing it's not
plagiarism but people wouldn't it's what
people call plagiarism what people
accuse Ellen White of as plagiarism is
not plagiarism at all it's literary
borrowing and
we find it in the Bible let's go to
Ecclesiastes chapter 12.
Ecclesiastes chapter 12
I have verse 10. I think we need to
start in verse 9 there though
yeah we do we need to start in verse
nine I have verses 10 and 11.
Ecclesiastes 12 verse 9.
moreover
because the preacher Solomon is speaking
of himself here if you've read the book
of Ecclesiastes you know when he talks
about the preacher he's speaking in of
himself and moreover because the
preacher was wise he still taught the
people knowledge yes he what
pondered in what
sought out what does it say there Kevin
explored
and what a range do you have mine says
set in order what does yours say anybody
have different
weighing and studying and what else
and arranging
many Proverbs what's he telling us there
an agreeable
he's saying that Solomon says I didn't
write all the Proverbs I just collected
them and put them in order
I searched him out I found wise saying
and I collected him in this book called
proverbs
Solomon is a literary borrower he must
not he must be a false prophet
I told you the other day the reason we
run into all of these these these these
issues is because we don't understand
the Bible as well as we should
this is the way the Bible was now I'm
going to show you something else that's
very interesting well let's read on
verse 11. verse 10 rather the preacher
sought to find acceptable words and what
was written was upright words of truth
in other words he had to find out and
pull out things that were truth from
error I'm sure he found things that
might have had a good thought in it but
he says this isn't all exactly how it
should read and he pulled out the piece
of Truth you follow that
and he sought out these words words of
truth verse 11 the words of the wise are
like goads the words of Scholars
are like well-driven nails given by one
Shepherd
given by what
one Shepherd who's the originator of all
truth
that's all he's saying I searched out by
the inspiration of the spirit of the
Lord by the way those things that were
true
okay now right there in same passage uh
well close to it chapter 11. look at
chapter 11 with me
I want you to pick up something here
verse 4 chapter 11 verse 4.
he who observes the what
the what
okay he who observes the wind does not
will not sow
he who regards the clouds will not reap
as now what's he talking about here
harvesting what
is he talking about harvesting grain
what's the what's the application he
regards the clouds he regards the wind
won't sow why if it's windy out I'm not
going to plant my seed why
he's gonna blow it all over the place he
who regards the wind does not plant the
seed he regards the clouds doesn't reap
it's going to rain today I'm not going
to get out there and try to harvest it
today
verse 5 as you do not know what is the
way of the Wind
or
he's liking it to likening the wind to
something
or how the bones grow in the what
womb of her who is with child
so you do not know the works of God who
makes everything
in the morning sow your seed and in the
evening do not withhold your hand
now what's he saying
you guys when you're going out to give
studies to somebody
and you're trying to regard the wind and
see if the spirit's blowing or not uh
this person doesn't seem interested I'm
not going to sell my seed there
right
that's cloudy it looks the the the the
the this Outlook is forbidding I don't
think this person's a good interest
it's not time to reap
he says you don't know
just like you don't know the way of the
wind neither do you know what
the way of the what
the way of the spirit
wow
what's that remind you of
does that remind you of anything
just didn't isn't that John chapter 3.
let's look at John chapter 3 for a
minute
well could it be that Jesus borrowed
from Ecclesiastes and didn't give credit
John chapter 3 Matthew Mark Luke John
chapter 3
and verse 8.
John chapter 3
in fact if we pick up on
the whole passage chapters 3 verse 3
Jesus answered Nicodemus and said most
assuredly I say to you unless one is
what
born again so he's talking about birth
he cannot see the kingdom of God
Nicodemus argues with him how can it be
Jesus says most assuredly I say to you
unless one is born of water in the
spirit he can't enter the kingdom of God
and in verse 8 he says the wind blows
where it wishes and you can hear the
sound of it but can't tell where it
comes from or where it goes so is
everyone who is born of the spirit
the way the wind works is just like the
way the spirit works in the forming like
deforming the child in the womb
who was it that gave that original idea
come on
the Lord did
and then he spoke it through Solomon
Jesus couldn't have possibly been
plagiarizing his own words through
Solomon anyway or through anybody else
but the point is he gives no credit here
but do you see he's saying exactly the
same thing he's picking up the same
thing Solomon said and this isn't the
only place I haven't put down every
place if you read through especially a
lot of the Proverbs you'll see Jesus
incorporates them in a lot of things he
never cites you know Solomon said
you don't hear it there
so if you've got to condemn Ellen White
for literary borrowing you're going to
have to condemn Jesus you're going to
have to condemn Solomon are you with me
on that
and too many too many of these folks get
on these websites they don't know that
they don't know they're going from a
whole wrong premise
so we have examples in the scripture of
literary borrowing now I want to just
touch on this section of literary
assistance for a moment literary
assistance a literary assistant is
somebody obviously you write out and
they help you in putting together what
you wrote
Ellen White had literary assistance she
had secretaries she had people who would
help her with her writing help
formatting it help in correcting it and
editing it and people said well how
could she be a true Prophet remember
what I said the other day this is the
problem that comes in when you have
verbal inspiration a verbal
inspirationist how can you have an
editor
God gave you what you wrote by dictation
write this word then this word then this
word and you're gonna let somebody edit
it
but with thought inspiration that's not
an issue
you may say well wait a minute I'm okay
you're shaking my Faith Pastor well I'm
going to shake your faith in the Bible
here in a minute then because the Bible
authors have literary assistance
see we don't see anything in Ellen
White's gift that wasn't in the
scripture in the Bible
uh let's go to First Corinthians 12 28
first
Corinthians 12 and verse 28.
First Corinthians 12 and verse 28 now
this is a gift a list of spiritual gifts
but I want you to notice one of these
gifts
First Corinthians 12 and look at verse
28 with me says here in God has
appointed these in the church
first apostles second prophets third
teachers after that Miracles then Gifts
of healings then what
helps and what
administrations you mean Administration
is a gift different types of
administration or gift
there are multiple gifts of the Spirit
question does everybody have the same
gift
does God expect everybody to have the
same gift no that chapter right there in
First Corinthians chapter 12 talks about
in fact verse 8 for to one is given the
word of wisdom through the spirit to
another the word of knowledge through
the Same Spirit to another Faith by The
Same Spirit to another gift of healings
Etc and it says
verse 11 but one in the same Spirit
works all these things Distributing to
each one individually as he Wills for as
the body is one and has many members but
all the members of that one body being
many are one body so also is Christ
what would happen if your arm and your
hand did not cooperate with your brain
and your mouth when you wanted to eat
let me have a drink
what would happen the body works
together okay same with the church and
I'm going to tell you from understanding
spiritual gifts
I would be more concerned if Ellen White
didn't have literary assistance than if
she did